we have a voicemail number it's to 192
david p you might remember a couple
weeks ago the kansas troll called in
live and tried to troll us and
completely face-planted so now he's back
to just leaving voicemails and here's
just an example of one of the many
people who is hoping that the youtube
advertiser boycott takes us down take a
listen to this you know what Pakman this
entire beggin scenario that you created
since the ad pocalypse has started is so
disgusting
you don't conform to the social demands
of employment and you think you're above
it but you still think that you're
entitled in respect and expect
generosity and in lifestyle comfort
that's that us hard-working adults have
when you don't actually work you need a
reality check Pakman life's tough and
the general general public are cont and
you'll get nothing for nothing
alright deal with it buddy yeah so
anyway obviously this continues the
theme that producing a nationally
syndicated program Monday through Friday
would staff and a studio and deadlines
is somehow not a real job but that aside
I've said it before and I'll say it
again people like the Kansas troll want
the YouTube ad boycott to pull us off
the air
my belief is our core audience
understand the importance of the
existence of the David Pakman show and
is not going to allow that to happen and
there's a few ways for you to do that
membership is one of them david
pakman.com slash membership record
record number of new subscribers in the
month of April through membership the
coupon code is available I voted 17
patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow you can pledge any
amount of money you want many people
pledging $1 or $2 as of right now we are
six patrons away from reaching 1500
patrons our immediate goal is 2,000
patrons and will be about 3/4 of the way
there with just six more patrons even if
you can only do a dollar a month most
people can put together a dollar a month
and if you can't don't worry about it
because we produce the show for
everybody not just for people who can
pay but if you if you're one of the
people that can put together a dollar a
month please go to patreon.com/scishow
VAD Pakman show and do
and of course if you ever shop on Amazon
remember that before going to Amazon you
go to david pakman.com slash amazon then
everything you buy will send us a
kickback all right so the kansas city
troll the kansas troll rather my hope is
that he's going to be disappointed that
the show is going to stay on the air on
the bonus show today Wikipedia founder
Jimmy Wales is fighting fake news we
will talk about how economic mobility
has been cut in half over the last 80 or
so years I will also tell you about a
man who pushed Foam down toilets for
nine years has been finally caught by
police it's a weird story but we'll
discuss that and much more on the bonus
show sign up at david pakman.com to get
instant access and I will speak to you
then